it was first settled by the greeks and
then became part of the roman empire
and with a history that long naples
italy is a place
filled with tradition but now as chris
lives they tells us
one of their friendlier customs is being
updated as the community struggles with
covid19
the second wave of the pandemic has been
brutal in naples both in terms of public
health as well as the economy
but there's a time-honored custom here
that's helping heal
both of those wounds a custom that
started
in the coffee shop
the people of naples are fiery and
caffeinated
even amid pandemic restrictions their
famous espresso
and a tradition of kindness lives on
it's called
the cafe a pay it forward
cup of coffee
so it goes like this you pay for your
coffee but then
you leave something extra then the next
time somebody comes in who can't afford
a coffee
well that something extra you left
behind pays for their coffee
that's the cafe so basil
now imagine an equivalent for someone
who can't afford a covet test
at the church of san severo foreign
appropriate for social distancing
locals get tested pay then
leave something extra to purchase tests
for those
in need some leave a few euros others
a lot more you just donated 100 euros
what compelled you to do
[Music]
people in this neighborhood are having a
rough time says organella biondi
i'm one of the lucky ones who still has
a job
so far some 2 000 people have received
free kova tests here and at other
locations
says mario donatiello a volunteer
organizer with the sanjonato charity
when you give it doesn't make you poorer
it makes you richer
he says naples is known for its
generosity
it's also a city known for its ingenuity
take these food baskets a clever
conveyance long used to avoid lugging
groceries upstairs
neapolitans above are now using them to
donate groceries to the needy
below pulling together whether it be
food baskets
covet tests or cups of coffee is what
makes naples
naples and it's moving to see people dig
deep to help out their neighbors the
testing organizers tell me it's almost
always the people who have the least
that end up giving the most for cbs this
morning saturday chris livesay
naples what a wonderful message from
abroad which people are doing
here as well in different ways and you
think of monday and martin luther king
day in a day of service
if you can every little bit makes a
difference yeah it certainly does
but isn't that so often the case those
who have used to give
give the most